Dasia ist die Stimme Deutschlands oder
beruhigt die Stimme von Nevada
Matt Larson Interview exklusiv per Klick,
also als heftigen Kommentar Ian über das Biest und darüber
, wie gut die Dinge laufen. Ja,
danke,
mein neues Album Spark kommt gerade heraus
und ich bin dabei  sehr aufgeregt darüber, aber du
hattest die Pause, bevor du das Album veröffentlicht hast,
ja, warum machen manche Künstler jedes Jahr ein Album,
ich weiß genau, der Erfolg, wenn
mich ein Song erreichen könnte, war sehr
überwältigend und ich wurde eingeladen,
nach Deutschland und Österreich zu kommen  Die Schweiz
auf Tour und ich habe es geliebt zu touren, also habe ich
das eine ganze Weile gemacht, aber dann wollte ich auch ein neues
Album machen, ein drittes Album. Ich habe
die ganze Zeit über all das nachgedacht, während ich auf
Tour war, dann musste ich schreiben und  Auch dafür brauchte ich
Zeit. Ich schreibe alle meine eigenen
Songs, also hatte ich nach dieser langen Tour eine
siebenmonatige Pause in New York City, warum
New York,
warum nicht auf dem Land in irgendeinem
Land der Welt. Ich denke, es klingt
ziemlich paradox  dass ich nach New ging
York City, um Ruhe zu finden,
um genau Musik zu lesen, Sie wissen, sehr chaotisch,
sehr laut, und vor allem
bin ich dorthin gegangen, um mich zu isolieren, um
alleine zu sein. Ich habe dort ein paar Freunde, aber
nicht so viele, und wenn ich nach Oslo gehe, Sie
Ich weiß, ich vermisse meine Leute so sehr. Ich vermisse
meine Familie und meine Freunde, wenn ich reise.
Wenn ich also nach Hause gehe, bin ich am Ende genauso
gesellig wie auf Tour zu Hause, und wenn
ich so gesellig bin, schreibe ich nicht, es ist nur
So wie es ist, ging ich nach New York City.
Ich wusste nicht, wie lange ich dort
bleiben würde, aber ich
blieb ungefähr sieben Monate dort, und ich denke,
der Kontrast und die Energie,
die zwischen ihnen auftrat, kennen Sie  Lärm und
die Verrücktheit in der Stadt, die sich
jeden Tag ändert, wenn ich zuschaue, was du aus der Asylwohnung kennst,
mit meinen nur meinen Instrumenten
und sie Tage haben, die sich nur
auf das Schreiben konzentriert haben, weil dein Album nicht
nach New York klingt, ich höre keinen
Klang von New  York oder Melodie oder irgendetwas
, das sich daran erinnert, es gesehen zu haben  was denkst du
, wie New York klingt, klingt
eher wie ein Country-Sound,
abgesehen von entspannenden Gefühlen, guten Gefühlen,
diese Geschichte, danke,
ja, das ist sehr gut. Ich mag sie
sehr. Ich habe sie mehrmals in meinem
Auto gehört  Nicht
wahr, die meiste Musik funktioniert am besten im Auto. Ich
liebe es, Musik im Auto
zu hören. Es ist schön, die Zeit zu haben, ein
ganzes Album von Anfang an zu hören.
Eventuell gab es einen Moment, in dem Sie
dachten, New York ist nicht so gut alle
waren  Ich habe
es geliebt, dort zu schreiben. Ich habe es geliebt, dass sich meine Tage nur
darum drehten, wann ich
schreiben würde, und ich werde heute keine Zeit zum
Schreiben haben. Ich habe auch einige schöne
neue Freunde gefunden. Ich habe viele Bands gesehen, die
nie zu mir kamen  nach Norwegen, um
viel neue Musik zu spielen. Ich sprach
jeden Tag Englisch, also fing ich schließlich
an, auf Englisch zu denken und zu träumen,
und es war ein natürlicherer Ansatz,
in etwas zu schreiben, das nicht
meine Muttersprache ist, was ich nicht mochte
ab  aus New York ist das so weit weg von
auch ihr wisst ich bin ich verbrachte ungefähr 200
Tage im Jahr auf Tour, jetzt ist es unglaublich und
Skype hat definitiv mein
Tourleben revolutioniert es macht es jetzt einfacher, dass
ich sie zumindest auf einem Bildschirm sehen kann und
aber  Es war ein bisschen schwierig,
mich selbst davon zu überzeugen, dass ich die richtige Entscheidung getroffen hatte
, dass das wichtig genug war, aber
als Songwriter ist es ein so großer Teil dessen, wer
ich bin. Ich werde immer sehr unruhig, wenn
ich nicht in Öl geschrieben habe
wichtig, das aus meinem System zu bekommen
und danach ging ich zurück zu auch ich war
umgeben von den Menschen, die ich liebe und ich
bekam etwas, du weißt schon,
Familie und Freunde
für eine Weile, das ist eine Belohnung für
all die Monate in New York
Alle deine Freunde wieder zu treffen und deine Familie
zu besuchen, fühlt sich jetzt auch immer wie eine
Belohnung an, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich es
ständig vermisse. Ich kenne die Stadt
und die Leute. Die Straße direkt vor
meiner Haustür ist eine sehr belebte Straße und
ich  kann einfach da runter gehen und dann ich  et
du weißt, zehn bekannte Gesichter zu sehen. Das gefällt mir
daran, in einer kleinen Stadt zu leben. Also,
was du jetzt machst, ist deine zweite
Karriere, wenn ich dann bin, ist es richtig,
weil du sagen kannst, dass du vorher eine
Karriere hattest, und es war eine ganz
andere  musik, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
, war es immer noch popmusik, es
war die art von popmusik, die ich geschrieben habe,
als ich salz empfohlen habe, ja, wir
waren nicht glücklich darüber, dass wir unseren
plattenvertrag bekommen haben, als wir 15 und 16 jahre
alt waren in amerika  Weißt du, für norwegische
Mädchen war es sehr aufregend, und wir
haben unser Album aufgenommen und unzählige Songs
mit großartigen Pop-Songwritern geschrieben, und
gerade als unser Ofen
herauskam, eröffnete sich die Gelegenheit,
einen Song auf dem Pokemon-Soundtrack zu haben,
und jetzt im Nachhinein  Natürlich kann ich
sehen, dass es eine großartige Gelegenheit
für uns war, und diese Single wurde Gold, ich
glaube, sie verkaufte sich 500.000 Mal. Ich meine,
es war keine andere Zeit als, aber es
war verrückt, aber Sie können sich vorstellen
, 16 17 zu sein  Ja  rs alt als es
herauskam und einen Song auf dem
Pokemon-Soundtrack zu haben, der nicht cool ist, nein, es
war nicht cool, aber ich denke, es hat uns
die Tür zu vielen neuen Zuhörern geöffnet
, und deshalb war es gut, ja, ist es
möglich  eine Karriere zu ändern oder ist es
schwierig, eine Karriere zu ändern und zu entscheiden, dass
ich diese Musik nicht mehr
machen möchte, ich möchte einen komplett anderen
Sound machen und nein,
ich denke wirklich nicht, ähm, solange
du kreativ bist  Kontrolle, du kannst machen,
was du willst.
Ich denke, in einem Duo zu sein, war zunächst einmal großartig,
weil du weißt, dass du
jemanden hast, der die Arbeitslast mit dem
Reisen, all den neuen Erfahrungen, dem
Druck und auch all den kleinen
Triumphen teilt, von denen du weißt, dass du jemanden hast, für den du jemanden hast
wirklich mit feiern und es war so
gut, für diese Zeit zu sein, und diese vier
Jahre waren von unschätzbarem Wert, weißt du, ich, ich, ich
würde es nie gegen etwas eintauschen, aber
dann bin ich zu uns zurückgekehrt, also hatte ich ein paar
Jahre Zeit, um Dinge nachzuholen, die ich
gewesen war  verpassen, es führt kein Weg
daran vorbei  Und wissen Sie, ich musste zu
Konzerten gehen und Wein trinken und mir wurde das
Herz gebrochen und all diese Dinge,
die obligatorisch sind, wenn Sie ein Teenager sind
, die ich nicht tun konnte, und das hat mir
wirklich Spaß gemacht, und es kam so viel
Musik  von einfach in einem Zustand zu sein, in dem
du keine Musik für ein Album machst
, das bestimmt herauskommen wird, als hätte ich keine
Ahnung, ob ich überhaupt ein Publikum als
Solokünstler habe, also habe ich einfach Musik geschrieben,
weil ich welche wollte  ist
natürlich so wie es sein soll und
plötzlich ist mir klar geworden ich muss teilen ich
muss diese musik teilen ich bin noch nicht
fertig mit der musikindustrie
ich versuche es nochmal und ich brauche es wirklich
diese Zuhörer zu finden, damit ich auf
Tour gehen kann, damit ich wieder aufs Pferd steigen kann,
und das habe ich getan und mit
allem, was ich gelernt habe, und das hat
sich als eine großartige Erfahrung für
mich als Solokünstler erwiesen, weißt du  Ich habe einige
Fehler gemacht, die ich jetzt nicht
machen muss, eine Pause zwischen den beiden
Koreas war sehr imp  Ich denke, es
war eine Jugend und definitiv, denn
als sich diese Gelegenheit ergab, wissen Sie,
Musik in 22
Ländern zu veröffentlichen, war verrückt,
es war ein riesiges Abenteuer, und natürlich
kann man zu so etwas nicht nein
sagen  war großartig, aber ich denke, die Presse, die
ich gemacht habe, weil ich eine kleine
Pause gemacht und mich davon zurückgezogen habe, und
Sie wissen auch, wie wertvoll
es ist, zu wissen, dass es nicht aufhören kann, wenn Sie wollen, dass es
aufhört, weil es verrückt ist  Das Leben
ist seltsam Ich bringe viele Opfer
Ich bin weg von den Menschen, die ich liebe Ich reise,
aber auf eine Weise, die nicht sehr
interessant ist, wissen Sie, warum ich von
A nach B gezogen bin und dann Interviews in
einem Hotel mache und  dann spiele ich nachts Konzerte
, was ich liebe, und darauf komme ich hinaus
, und eines der wertvollsten
Dinge, die ich gelernt habe, ist, dass man wirklich
für diese musikalischen Momente leben muss, und
ich darf jeden Tag im Jahr Musik spielen
bei weitem meine Lieblingsbeschäftigung
auf der ganzen Welt und deshalb ist es so
es lohnt sich für mich okay, also ist es sehr
wichtig, nicht zu berühmt zu sein und
Pausen zu haben. Ich denke, man könnte sagen,
dass man das sagen könnte, weil
ich an Justin Bieber denke, ja, er hat
keine Chance, eine Pause zu machen oder zu  Sei
nicht so berühmt, ich weiß, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
wie es ist, Justin Bieber zu sein, aber
du willst es nicht, ich will nicht, ich will nicht,
es ist zu viel und im Moment bin ich so glücklich
mit meinem Leben, im Moment
Ich werde reisen Ich werde großartige Orte an
wunderschönen Orten sehen Ich werde
für ein Publikum spielen, das mich für
mich will Ich bin nicht Ich spiele keine Rolle
Ich bin sicher, Justin Bieber spielt keine
Teilweise ist das nicht das, was ich sage,
aber ich bin nicht diese Art von Berühmtheit, auch
wenn ich frei habe, kann ich
einfach tun, was ich will, und ich habe das
Glück, eine Plattenfirma zu haben
, die mich unterstützt  so sehr,
dass sie mich recht lassen, so lange ich
will, und wenn ich bereit bin, ein neues
Album zu veröffentlichen, sind sie da, um es zu unterstützen. Ich
denke, das ist sehr selten, ich  Ich bin sehr dankbar
dafür, dass ich andere Künstlerfreunde habe,
die jetzt
so viel Glück haben, okay, jetzt hatte ich keine Leute,
die mich in New York anriefen und mich belästigten, zu
fragen, wo verfügbar. Ja,
du kämpfst gegen Kidsongs, es
gab keinen solchen Druck, okay